- [Narrator] Puppies,
they're the furry friends
we take for granted.
But, how does having one affect us?
(upbeat music)
- My name is Meg Olmert
and I'm the author of
"Made For Each Other: the biology
of the human-animal bond."
Our journey with dogs began
about 45,000 years ago
according to the latest
archeological evidence.
It preceded many hundreds
of thousands of years
with a more casual, and
perhaps distant, pragmatic
relationship with wolves as well.
But about 45,000 years ago we
start to see the bones change
and indications that A, dogs
are certainly living with us.
And that living with us
appears to have had certain
effects on their biology
and their physiology.
That is what enabled them to
become our best friends.
- [Narrator] How does
this relationship work?
- There is a feedback system
that both neurochemically
and psychologically and behaviorally
that sets up between you and your pet.
And how good you are to your pet
is often exactly reflected back.
Although, what I would say
is they tend to be wildly generous.
More generous than we are.
So, that is why, you know,
they'll be wagging their tail,
you know, thrilled to see
you when you come home
or if it's a cat it's purring.
And you may be very
distracted but they aren't.
You are the greatest thing they ever saw
if you've developed this relationship.
If you've earned it.
You have a different
relationship with your own pet
versus your, even your
neighbor's pet, because it's,
that's your closer family.
It's a different kind of bond
and when they do FMRI studies
just like a mother will
have certain brain regions
light up very strongly in the dopamine
and oxytocin rich areas
when they look at a picture
of their baby versus just another infant.
When you look at a picture of
your dog versus another dog,
you see the same thing.
If you love dogs you're
gonna get this reward
to a degree whether you are
looking at your dog or not.
Do therapy dogs work?
Well they certainly can.
Dogs can do amazing things.
With our program Warrior Canine Connection
we work with service members
and veterans with
post-traumatic stress disorder.
We have the patients who say, "This dog
is better than any drug I ever took.
I didn't sleep for five
years until this dog
slept next to me."
- [Narrator] What happens to your body
when you're with your dog?
- [Meg] Your heart rate comes down,
your blood pressure comes down,
your heart rate variability
which is the ability
of the heart to duck and dive
and respond to stress improves.
You release oxytocin, the opioids,
adrenaline, and serotonin.
So, all of these great reward chemicals
and anti-stress chemicals can be released
in both you and the pet.
- [Narrator] What is oxytocin?
- Oxytocin is a very ancient chemical.
It's in all social mammals.
There's variations on it
that you find in birds
and in turtles, and in worms.
And it most effectively is
known for releasing breast milk
and creating labor contractions.
That's what it was first known for.
So in a sense, it is the
quintessential mammalian hormone
since live birth and production
of breast milk identifies us
as mammals and mammary glands, et cetera.
About 25 years ago they discovered
that besides the oxytocin
receptors and cells in the body
that are producing oxytocin
in the breast and the
uterus, lo and behold,
it's produced throughout the
brain and in all the areas
that control behavior and emotion.
So what was it doing there?
And what they discovered was
that it was talking to other
classic brain neurotransmitters
such as serotonin,
and dopamine and adrenaline,
and the opioid system.
And it was setting up, by
doing that, this perfect
mental physiologic state of calm.
It is the most powerful
drive and it creates the bond
that lasts a lifetime.
That's how strong it is.
(happy music)